[inaudible] [inaudible]
you already know that the word language
refers to our ability to communicate
with speech.
But we saw that what exactly that ability
is turned out to be quite a quagmire.
So now let's turn to the other
thing we mean by language. You know,
the specific languages we
speak with their own words,
their own grammar and their
own pronunciation. I mean,
English is a language,
right? And this is English,
but so is this. And back in time,
this was English even further back,
but we call this English
to wait. I get it.
This is old English and this one is
middle English and this is modern English.
So are these three languages or three
different stages of the same language?
Uh, but I know history is always
messier than we want it to be.
So let's just stick to the present.
Here are some basic words in English,
and these are the same words in a
totally different dialect of English.
They're two dialects.
Because if the same language gets spoken
in different ways by different groups
of people, we call those
different dialects. Moving on,
let's translate those words into
Norwegian. The Norwegian language,
and here's how we would write
those same words in Swedish,
the Swedish language,
so Swedish and Norwegian
are different languages,
but British and Scottish are different
dialects of the same language.
Where's the line between a
dialect and a language anyway?
Is it just arbitrary or conventional?
Maybe in the end it really
is buttoned up by a phrase.
Max Vine ride passed along during the
lecture series he gave in the 1940s a
member of his audience made the witty
remark a language is a dialect with an
army and a navy if that's so,
it's about politics and power just
as much as it's about grammar,
language versus languages,
languages versus dialects.
Oh, what a mess I've dragged
you into. And with that,
I welcome you to my youtube channel.
Subscribe if you want to learn more,
because from the looks of it,
we've seriously got some
stuff to sort out together.